hello readers today I'm in a courthouse
watching people argue about laws so we
can learn about the power of evidence
evidence is essentially proof it is the
facts that help you know that something
is true let's listen in and your honor
that is why we propose that cookies be
made illegal the prosecution rests hmm
very interesting indeed objection your
honor I may be a simple country lawyer
but even I can see that my opponent has
neglected to offer up a single crumb of
evidence in favor of banning all cookies
only heated and offensive ain't a cookie
slogans objection sustained
you will give evidence for your claims
or I will dismiss this case in favor of
cookies you have not yet proved that
cookies pose a threat to public health
show me where it says in our books of
law that I even have the right to make
this ruling both of you are going to
need to give me evidence okay so you can
see that there were a couple of things
happening here there's a group of people
who want to keep cookies a group of
people who want to ban cookies and in
the middle of it a judge who has to
decide which group of people is right so
she asked them for evidence if you
believe cookies are bad what's your
proof if you believe cookies are good in
moderation what's your proof let's step
out of the courtroom for a second and go
to this example in a text I'm in big
trouble I forgot to do the social
studies project last weekend in my
defense I did have a very unusual
weekend my stepdad Zeke unexpectedly
picked me up from school last Friday
because he got free tickets to the
Dodgers game then since the game got
over late we decided to stay at my
grandma's house because she lives sort
of by the stadium in the morning she
asked if we could paint her garage of
course we did but it took all day on
Sunday I'm sorry to report I devoted my
entire day to watching Voltron let's try
answering some questions that require us
to look back at the text for evidence
this is like the bedrock of any kind of
writing if you make a claim you have to
back it up with evidence so did the
author remember to do their social
studies project last weekend
No and why do we know that they say so
in the very first line I forgot to do
the social studies project okay that's
easy mode you're saying fine what did
the author of this piece do on Saturday
you'll notice the word Saturday doesn't
appear in the paragraphs above and yet I
could tell you with confidence and to
direct support from the text how well
let's go back and look at the text my
stepdad Zeke unexpectedly picked me up
from school last Friday and we keep
reading then since the game got over
late we decided to stay at my grandma's
house because she sort of lives by the
stadium so the author and their stepdad
spent the night Friday night at
Grandma's house the story continues in
the morning she the grandma asked if we
could paint her garage of course we did
but it took all day which morning
Saturday morning I'm pulling information
directly out of the text to support my
answer the author spent Saturday
painting their grandmother's garage ooh
hold on let's head back to the
courthouse I think the judge is ready to
issue her verdict and decide the case
this Court will come to order please
order thank you we've heard the
arguments of the prosecution and the
defense both anti cookie and Pro cookie
and now the time has come to give my
judgment the anti cookie side presented
a very interesting case showing the
effects of cookie exposure to teeth and
the dangerous effects of having too much
sugar and feeling all Wibbly but the pro
cookie side also gave very compelling
evidence showing the in moderation a
cookie can be a very tasty snack indeed
provided that you treat them for what
they are something to have every so
often this Court finds in favor of the
cookie thank you Wow readers I think we
just witnessed something important and
historic and it couldn't have happened
without the power of evidence you can
learn anything David out
you